what's happening to reject nation Greg
Alba here John we are going to watch
three trailers today in the midst of all
the craziness so many trailers dropping
this week there's a few that we missed
out on and so we figured we'd play
catch-up right now and instead of just
spreading out a bunch of videos we're
gonna do a special three trailer edition
for you guys want to make a couple of
disclaimers here first disclaimer we
know III is coming up and my gaming
friends are there most of them were
going to e3 first of all and the ones
that are gonna be able to come by swing
by here are you available from Monday
through Wednesday and even though I've
got him back into gaming this year I
would still like from one of my gaming
friends to be here per video I just feel
more comfortable that way because we
like to actually provide you know good
opinions and insight after the reaction
is done transition to second disclaimers
if you are real fans of this channel
you'll notice that most of the time when
we do reactions and reviews we like to
actually take our time with going a
little more in-depth into the videos and
we like to put a lot of inserts and
edits into the review portion because
this is a catch-up video yes there'll be
jump cuts like this one but we're gonna
you know trim it back on some of the
inserts and all that because we've still
got some catching up to do for our
patreon supporters over there for the TV
show reactions and everything we're just
trying to handle it all as a two-man
crew right now but we know there's a lot
of requests for these three movies and
here the timestamps if you just want to
skip to them mortal engines man the old
man and the gun these are the three
movies we're gonna talk about right now
and yeah little catch-up video for you
guys so we're gonna keep the review
portion short on these like most
reaction channels and we're gonna just
freeze right through these today so
seems only fitting for the first trailer
to be first man Damien Chazelle and Ryan
Gosling's newest movie let's get to it
using me IMAX movie out here
there's the Gosling stare the image
first man to walk on the moon
that'd be something we've chosen a job
so difficult so happy to see you
requiring development we're gonna have
to start from scratch by Chandler
crazy IMAX experience only after we
mastered these tests do we consider ID
to land on the moon
whoa knew if his flight is successful
you'll go down in history what kind of
thoughts do you have about that we're
planning on the flight being successful
and that is a big mother the vehicles
going to work but we have every
intention of coming back
[Music]
any question whether the program's worth
the cost in money in the last you down
here and they look up and you don't
think about it too much
a Space Exploration changes your
perception and it allows us to see
things that we should have seen a long
time ago
yeah fairly recognized Adam do you think
he makes it do you think he makes it ja
was a spoiler yeah no no he just finds
you know the secret Nazi base and it's a
Segway riding an Iron Sky yeah alright
some quick thoughts on this I am wildly
impressed that Damien Chazelle has this
master caliber of range you know he
showed with whiplash that he can do an
intense drama and then he does this
beautiful musical with lala land and now
he's back to this which is like a period
piece a true story supposedly and it
feels like a 60s movie he liked the way
it shot on like some type of film grain
that I'm looking at here it looks like a
60s film this looks intense I wasn't
expecting that I wasn't expecting an
intense experience and I heard he shot a
lot of this with IMAX cameras which is
like the best way to experience any
space movie in my opinion yes shooter
with IMAX cameras and it looks like a
great experience to be on because I've
always heard you know we all know if
you're American Neil Armstrong landing
on the moon and all that but I never
really looked into what led to that and
the journey to actually be able to get
there so seeing this trailer makes me go
I feel like I should watch this even
though it's gonna be a lot of drama tiny
stuff here I feel like this is something
I should watch as an American I should
check this out oh yeah I'm just
highlighting like the risk and the true
danger because there are a lot of space
movies that make it feel like an
adventure and this is clearly
highlighting what is so intense about
the decision to go to space and probably
with the psychological toll is gonna be
of that and yeah just the way that
they're shooting this the intimacy kind
of ramps up all the intensity and for me
one of the things I appreciate it most
about a film like interstellar is how
amazing some of those IMAX Space modules
sequences are and I got to imagine that
for a film like this there's gonna be a
ton of that kind of imagery especially
for one that it's gonna heavily rely on
realism you know films like interstellar
and gravity that made for great space
imax experiences ya have a lot of things
that you're like that's pretty illogical
you can't do that you know yeah they get
science fiction
they get a little fantasy we're here
this is a true story so you got to stick
to as realistic as possible yeah what
you're doing which I think can make for
an arguably more immersive experience if
you're gonna do it that level of realism
I guess my last question I have is
everyone who knows me knows I'm a huge
Ryan Gosling fan Ryan Gosling is my
favorite actor actually did a patreon
Q&A and one of the questions was who's
my celebrity governor mine was Ryan
Gosling
so Gosling is one of my idols right now
and I'll watch anything he's in I am a
little questionable about the
performance though only because the
trailer did not really give us scenes
we've got here's a lot of tone spectacle
intensity and he's playing a real person
so I would like to not see Ryan Gosling
when I'm seeing this performance grant
and I know he's not gonna be all makeup
and prosthetics and whatever everybody
hear a little bit of him speaking which
sounds like he's doing a bit of an
accent a bit of a voice change but I'm
hoping to see some like mannerism
changes something that embodies Neil
Armstrong granted I don't even know a
Neil Armstrong looks like but I want to
be there as a viewer thinking I'm
watching a dude that's not Ryan Gosling
yeah that was great that's great let's
move on to the next one whoo all right
so next on the list we're going with the
old man and the gun mortal engines I
imagine is the biggest spectacle of them
all so we'll save that for last the old
man in the gun Robert Redford know
nothing about it Fox Searchlight film is
about as far as it goes this is one of
our other highly requested ones to check
out so let's do it I think so yeah yeah
you know anything that Mars
[Music]
let's see why is that well because if I
told you you probably wouldn't want to
see me who said I was gonna see you
again
would you that's a smooth life is it
here let's take this place see it was a
bank and soon as I counter up there that
was really a tellers window and you just
walk in real calm so you walk right up
look her in the eye and you say ma'am
this is a robber and you show her the
gun like this and you say we want you to
get hurt cuz I like you I like you a lot
so don't go breaking my heart
okay excuse me I'd like to open up an
account well great what type of account
do you have in mind this kind this kind
he said he was armed they'd have a gun
you saw well he was also sort of a
gentleman he seemed like a nice is he
smile
see you smile Danny Glover 3 right yes
in two years you think you can catch him
myself
[Music]
his whole life locked up so for the
times that he broke out somebody should
have told me well you find something you
love
[Music]
Wow we're supposed to be you're never
exactly where you're supposed to be are
you to do whatever you know what I do
with the door closes but you about the
window perfect perfect that's that's
great that looks looks fantastic man I
mean if you ever needed a reminder of
just how charming Robert Redford and
[ __ ] Spacek yeah this reminds me of
like when Robert Redford did like those
Paul Newman collab flicks Butch Cassidy
in the this thing yeah outlaws are new
criminal activity Steele you know really
charming very charming guys and I don't
want to get to know him and this is a
period piece I find the advertising
interesting because we just watched
American animals that were planning on
squeezing in a movie beautiful that was
another one that was like a heist movie
based on a true story but it had like
kind of similar text advertising this
story is not true it is true and this
one has an advertising it's mostly true
you know can I see a trailer like this
I'm wondering like how much of this is
true beyond that though I honestly could
care less when I watch a movie knowing
what's true what's not sure like I'll
look that up after if I'm engaged enough
in the story this looks like a really
surprising leave like a delightful
experience yeah for the most
heartwarming robbery face yeah then it's
setting up
I kept thinking like oh it's about to
get crazy isn't it it's about to get
intense this guy's actually a crazy
criminal Robert dresses like everyone
just thinks this guys are really nice
all dude and no one's actually even seen
the gun
but still Casey Affleck has to catch him
it seems like back then you as much
easier to rob banks than it would be now
yeah yeah time progresses it gets harder
and harder to rob bank trust me this guy
knows it's the overall cast you know
Robert Redford [ __ ] Spacek Danny Glover
Casey Affleck who I hear was a great top
notch top notch those applicants killing
the game you can take up terms of public
opinion
they even got Tom Waits in here looking
like Ron Perlman maybe with a mustache
but I find fascinating about the movie
first man and then looking at this I
appreciate when films that are period
pieces go out of their way more than
just production design but also in
camera quality to look more along the
lines of the period that the film
actually came out in choosing like an
actual film stock or something like that
yeah and and that it provides that much
more authenticity to make it feel like
an older film to kind of funny that we
watch these trailers back to back and
you get kind of this experience
now we're head into a very Peter Jackson
this baby up alright guys mortal engines
this is the most requested ones so far
and if you made it this far
giving you a heads up we did shoot bad
times at El Royale on a separate video
that I'll be going up later here we go
immortal engines
only one have a trailer that is London
sixty minutes is all it took to bring
humanity to the very brink of extinction
mankind mobilized a new age arose in the
rearing age the great predator city's
survival of the fastest this is for my
mother
stop
ask him what you murdered my mother
I'm sorry you had to head
you go weaving sagon he won't stop until
I'm dead
unless you kill her first I want them
found
a lot of December movies
badass
I've been looking for you for a long
time
your mother she said she had found
something dangerous and she was afraid
of Valentine of what he might do man who
controls this controls the world
she said that you could stop him
this weapon from wipeout the largest
city in the blink of an eye
not if we shut it down
nothing can stand in the face of this we
have to stop London before it destroys
us
you sure you want to do this once we go
in there's no going back
I have to
hmm okay
people who wrote this work on the script
for Lord of the Rings - Oh Peter Jackson
did not direct this no no no in fact
somebody come into that earlier I think
it's got a stamp of approval most
certainly and it has some of that Peter
Jackson epic scope it's a chip off the
old block I mean I don't know how you
feel about this trailer I feel like this
has like a lot or I really like it
I don't either like I it's got a lot of
really cool designs and like a really
cool world and all that but all of the
like story beats I'm picking up and like
most of the dialogue is like a
completely stop I guess is based on a
book I don't know if it's like a why a
novel or whatever bottom line it feels
like that it feels like a y know this is
aa really the one I think I could put
the most time ripping apart yeah maybe
it's the idea to that we watched two
trailers that were about story and
characters so Emily and the emotional
experience here you know this is your
big Universal Pictures landscape and
crazy visual movie of course that
succeeds that definitely succeeds in
terms of like those are some pretty
badass design as much as like some of
this might be arguably cooler if you did
a little more practical stuff I imagined
to be very impossible a lot more money I
get that I don't know why just get the
impression that's kind of an empty film
well yeah because again all the all the
notes of story or motivation here are
subsetting people right now because yeah
I've heard this sort of whoever has this
whoever man has this guy in the world
and with a blink of an eye just could
wipe out an entire city and I'm like
these are the stakes for like every
blogger I found myself in this in this
situation halfway through going what do
I like about this trailer specifically
other than cool visuals it's like maybe
the action scenes will be cool honestly
and sometimes that suffices
sometimes it does sometimes that's like
good enough and I walked out and I kind
of forget about it you know but this
movie doesn't look like it's gonna be
short enough
this really looks like it's gonna be
like two and a half hours long it looks
like it's gonna be a quite a journey and
the only thing I kind of liked a little
more about it as compared to trailers or
movies that I've seen that are like this
you get more emphasis on who the villain
is and it seems like they're putting
good focus on that whereas a lot of the
time the villain here is usually kind of
just pushed in the background even they
slap a celebrity face on him here I felt
like Hugo Weaving was kind of leading
this trailer which is cool but then I'm
also like this looks like generic Hugo
Weaving I've seen him do agent Smith in
Red Skull this is the exact same kind of
performance yeah it's like I'm only
excited by his presence because I like
Hugo Weaving
look at that hey who knows I mean maybe
these could be just all like stock
trailer lines and maybe the whole movie
is gonna be a lot more intricate than
this yeah just everything they throw out
here it feels very familiar it's like my
mother and you know this is reluctant
boy is gonna help out this badass chick
and then they're gonna have to go over
this you go weaving performances look
like bland
they look like bland performances yeah
and it's funny as I'm sure these actors
are actually great it's just better
dealing with a movie like on this scale
it can be hard to get performances that
are grand and yeah if they're not gonna
be saying a lot to work with I'm talking
about like the performance is in the
context of the trailer of course I'm not
exactly a hundred percent sure if the
performances will actually suck it's
just right here it looks a little bit
bland the movie itself does not offering
anything all that unique other than a
different world and some different
designs that look like crazy or CGI fury
road inspired yeah you just take madman
rabbit into the dirigible from The Mummy
Returns and honestly like the teaser
trailer for this I did say that there
was like tense it was like a horror
movie until they started talking man and
then now this looks like a movie yeah
most of them are not good all right they
all can't be the hungry hey the fifth
wave let's not forget
all right guys voting time go to the
comments and tell us which trailer was
your absolute favorite a lot of you guys
want immortal engines start to let you
down that we didn't like it but we like
the other two we really like the other
two did and sometimes you don't like a
trailer
the way it goes to dramas is worth one
blockbuster yeah well you can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification Bell check us out on
patreon full line TV show reactions
weekly Q&A is would love to have you
become a patron Oh check today